Speaker 1: very interesting news.
Even though Joe Biden has not said he wants
to increase the number of justices on the
Supreme Court and is awaiting a report about
the Supreme Court, Democrats in the House
and Senate will be introducing legislation
that would do exactly that.
It would expand the number of seats on the
court from nine to 13.
Many progressive groups like it.
This is being led by Congressman Jerry Nadler,
Hank Johnson, Monder Jones.
And in the Senate, Senator Ed Markey likes
this same idea.
It is way too early to know whether this has
a shot in in the house.
I think, listen, without Joe Biden clearly
saying, let's do this, I don't think there's
any way in hell that it passes the Senate.
But it is a very interesting step that is
going to be taken.
I've said before, I'm open.
My general view is I am not that into ideas
that can be turned against those who implement
them, and I've said, you know, if you increase
from nine to 13, then the next time Republicans
have control, they could go from 13 to 17.
And that becomes sort of like a race to the
bottom.
And that doesn't seem great.
We have a unique situation, though, where
Republicans, to their credit, I mean, listen,
they pulled it off, but disgustingly argued
we don't put in new Supreme Court justices
during the last year of a presidential term
when Barack Obama nominated Merrick Garland.
And then with just weeks to go before an election
in twenty twenty, they pushed through the
Amy Amy CONI or Amy covid Barrett nomination
for Donald Trump to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
That, to me, passes a line where I believe
a threshold has been met for more sort of
aggressive action being needed.
So like I would be OK with expanding the court,
I would be worried about what the long term
impact would be.
We definitely need to be looking at term limits
on Supreme Court justices so that it's simply
predetermined.
You know, I don't know exactly how the numbers
would work out, but with nine justices on
the court, that means that there is one.
And with, you know, imagine it's nine justices,
18 year terms.
That means every six years there is a retirement
and a replacement and, you know, ahead of
time what the schedule of that is, whatever
the numbers would actually work out to.
I believe that that's something that would
be important to do.
And I very much support that now this bill.
When is Joe Biden going to take a position
on it?
My thought from the beginning was Joe Biden
is deliberately not taking a position in the
lead up to the election because it could be
misused one way or the other.
It's unclear what the benefit would be.
We were told Joe Biden would have a group
give him recommendations about what to do
with the Supreme Court.
Last week, we learned now the group's not
actually going to give recommendations.
It's just going to be a report about the state
of the judiciary and the court.
So then the question is, well, who is going
to give Joe Biden recommendations as to what
to do and when is he going to get those recommendations?
The way I see it right now is relatively cynical.
And it's this is going to be a punt.
And you're not going to hear I mean, he just
he won't expand the court.
He won't necessarily say I am committed never
to expanding the court.
He will just say at this time, I am not expanding
the court.
I'm not moving to expand the court.
And that that will go on and on.
That's my view.
If you think it'll go a different way.
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at the Pakman.
We have a fantastic show for you today.
This will be the best Friday show in at least
a week.
All right.
Stay with us.
We'll be
right back.